bonsoir je vous propose d'écouter ce
soir l'audition de serge blisko le
président de la miviludes la mission
interministérielle de vigilance et de
lutte contre les dérives sectaires
il était auditionné la semaine dernière
devant la mission d'information du sénat
soit l'accès aux données administratives
une mission demandée par le groupe
écologiste ici au sénat alors le
président de la miviludes serge blisko
observe une mutation des sectes les
grandes organisations laisse désormais
la place à de plus petits groupes plus
facile donc à contrôler surtout avec
thor des nouvelles technologies les
groupes sont donc maintenant plus petit
grâce à internet mais ils sont toujours
aussi dangereux a insisté serge blisko
voilà je vous proposerons tout de suite
dès l'écouté
nous accueillons aujourd'hui à sa
demande monsieur serge blisko qui est
président de la mission
interministérielle de vigilance et de
lutte contre les dérives sectaires la
mairie d'études monsieur le président
vous êtes médecin et président du
conseil d'administration de l'hôpital
sainte-anne
vous êtes accompagné par madame audrey
kaiser voilà qui est cancer de peau la
presse et relations que les élus et
madame elisabeth balaives et qui est
responsable du service documentation
alors monsieur le président vous êtes
sans doute venu par les difficultés
rencontrées face à certaines demandes
d'accès aux données que vous détenez
alors je vous donne la parole
ils viennent expliquer tout ça merci
tout d'abord un mesdames et messieurs
les émulateurs de de nous avoir
sollicité pour vous présenter
très rapidement le plus rapidement
possible ce qu'est notre métier
la miviludes à la miviludes la mission
interministérielle de vigilance et de
lutte contre les dérives sectaires et
notre position ainsi que notre notre
façon de réagir sur l'accès aux
documents administratifs et aux deux
républiques qui nous sont fréquemment
vous l'avez dit monsieur le président en
introduction
qui ne sont que nous sommes très
fréquemment sollicités donc je vais vous
rappeler que la miviludes fait partie de
son originalité puisque c'est un
organisme à peu près unique en europe
peut-être au monde c'est à dire un
organisme public dépendant des services
du premier ministre une mission
interministérielle créée le 28 novembre
2002 sa forme actuelle par le
gouvernement raffarin par décret alors
l'histoire vous la connaissez de la
miviludes ne s'appelait pas tout à fait
comme ça elle s'appelait mission
d'information et de lutte contre les
sectes autres miss au départ et ce en
fait c'est une initiative parlementaire
venue de l'assemblée nationale et du
sénat qui avait abouti par exemple en
2001 à la loi au vote de la loi dite
about-picard du nom de son de ces deux
protagonistes de ces deux de ces deux de
co2 rapporteur au sénat et à l'assemblée
nationale
j'ajoute ici en une façon tout à fait
tout à fait particulière que ce
dispositif et surtout cette mission a
toujours été portée par les pouvoirs
publics de façon unanime
quelle que soit la couleur politique des
gouvernements des assemblées et le vote
je crois que tu es toujours acquis à la
quasi unanimité de l'assemblée je
voulais en profiter pour remercier les
parlementaires qui nous ont toujours
fait confiance donc l'émission de la
miviludes crif dans le consensus
français de protection des victimes et
de l'ordre public la veille et la lutte
que nous menons contre les dérives
sectaires ne prend en compte que les
seuls à des comportements et
comportements contraires aux lois et
règlements portant atteinte aux droits
fondamentaux de la personne ou trouvant
en lan république je voudrais préciser
que quelles que soient nos opinions
personnelles sont très variées dans de
petites missions qui compte onze
personnes
une option philosophie politique
religieuse qui sont également très
diverses
nous nous attachons pas analysé
idéologiquement philosophiquement ou
spirituellement tel ou tel tel ou tel
groupement telle ou telle personne
chacun évidemment et nous sommes dans le
cadre de la liberté de conscience la
liberté de conviction la liberté de
religion et dans le cadre
le général de la loi de 1905 que que
nous respectons totalement et pour nous
en plus c'est quelque chose un garde un
garde-fou important et d'ailleurs nous
travaillons en étroite coopération avec
le bureau des cultes la direction des
libertés publiques glisse à l'intérieur
qui a une connaissance très maintenant
plus de 100 ans très fouillée des
dispositifs de défense de la laïcité et
qui répond à beaucoup de questions et
avec qui on travaille en parfaite
harmonie
donc nous informons le public sur les
risques voire les dangers auxquels est
exposée et nous facilitons la mise en
oeuvre d'actions d'un de victimes de
dérives sectaires
nous travaillons en particulier avec
grande association qui s'occupe de
dérives sectaires proprement dit comme à
tenir son nationale avec des
associations régionales où le ccmm roger
ikor qui ont tous les deux une trentaine
d'années d'existence et qui couvre plus
ou moins bien tout le territoire
national
nous travaillons également avec l'inavem
comme organisme de public
en tout cas aidé par le travaillons
beaucoup avec avec l'inavem sur cette
action des deux victimes est bien
évidemment nous sommes en contacts
quasiment quotidiens avec les services
de police de gendarmerie les
collectivités locales tout ce qu'ils
nous envoient nous demande la
magistrature qui nous demande un certain
nombre de précisions voir une capacité
je n'ose pas notre expertise à ce que le
terme est réservé à une signification
propre dans l'institution judiciaire
mais pour prendre un terme un terme
nouveau et un peu fleuri on a une
capacité d'être des sachants et donc des
experts entre guillemets sur un certain
nombre de problèmes vous dis très
simplement un juge d'instruction pour
nous appeler ouais je vais à faire
fulminer en disant j'ai un problème je
ne comprends pas très bien ce que nous
raconte cette personne ces familles il
semblerait qu'ils soient membres de dans
un groupement qui qui sont dans une
autre
logique plus plus inhabituel que ce que
nous connaissons habituellement et donc
est-ce que vous pouvez nous éclairer sur
ce que c'est que ce que cela voilà donc
nous le faisons évidemment bien
volontiers donc que nous sommes
organisés je voulais 10 sous l'autorité
d'un président la miviludes est
constitué une équipe permanente
interdisciplinaire dirigé par un
secrétaire général magistrats de l'ordre
judiciaire et des composés de
conseillers mis à disposition de tous
les ministères concernés par la
politique publique de lutte contre les
dérives sectaires l'intérieur la justice
la santé l'économie et les finances
l'éducation les affaires étrangères
alors cette longue énumération ne doit
pas vous faire croire que nous sommes un
organisme tentaculaire nous sommes une
douzaine en comptant une douzaine d
effectifs réalisés et 14 ou 15 à
l'effectif théorique et vous savez qu'il
est toujours difficile d'avoir un
effectif dans la fonction publique par
voie de détachement d'avoir un effectif
réaliser qu'ils soient égales à
l'effectif théorique donc voilà et nous
allons sur l'infrastructure de matignon
pour ce qui concerne les locaux nous
sommes installés rue à matignon rue
vaneau et notre secrétariat est assuré
par des services du premier ministre
donc nous avons six pôles importants et
madame césaire par s'occupe de la presse
et madame bnf qui est attachée
administrations centrales à matignon
salue le premier ministre est donc
responsable du service documentation du
service d'un service qui fait de
personnes donc mais nous continuons
malgré cette taille réduite mais qui a
assuré tout de même notre mission avec
parfois des difficultés parce que nous
sommes vraiment très peu nombreux mais
je crois que l'époque n'est pas à
l'inflation à l'inflation des
fonctionnaires ou des contractuels donc
je passe rapidement là dessus et nous
sommes en quelque sorte pilotée par un
comité exécutif de pilotage opérationnel
qu'on appelle ses pots dans le projet
avons qui réunit les représentants de
différentes grandes directions des
ministères concernés dans le décret dont
les directeurs ou des sous directeurs
d'administration centrale qui avec qui
nous discutons une fois par trimestre 2
de notre travail et du point de vue plus
j'ai déjà plus philosophique nous avons
un conseil d'orientation ouvert à la
société civile avec 30 membres où l'on
rencontre des parlementaires des deux
assemblées des représentantes fonction
publique nous vend associative du monde
médical
les acteurs économiques et sociales et
des professeurs d'université qui
viennent et qu'ils discutent à nos
orientations et qui sachant aussi sur la
façon que nous avons de ne travailler au
plan local
le décret précise que chaque département
doit au moins une fois par an ce qui
ferait sans réunion si ce programme
ambitieux été réalisées et pour le coup
une des raisons qui donnent raison dans
101 départements d'outre-mer de ce point
de vue est à son département et qui nous
pose beaucoup de difficultés parfois
donc dans les 100 départements français
nous devrions avoir une réunion parents
qui réunit l'ensemble des services
déconcentrés sous la codirection du
préfet du département et du procureur de
la république ou des procureurs
quentinois plus dans le ressort qui
coordonne et surtout informe s'informent
mutuellement et nous sommes présents en
tant que conseiller entre guillemets ou
consultants des dérives sectaires tels
qu'ils ont pu apparaître dans tel ou tel
dans telle ou telle partie du
département et surtout avec
l'institution judiciaire nous voyons le
cheminement judiciaire de ces affaires
sont très fréquents alors c'est un peu
je dirais la disposition du préfet sont
très fréquemment invité dans ces
départements
les représentants locaux de la société
par parler parfois dans une deuxième
partie
quand on a fini d'évoquer les affaires
individuelles et
également mais c'est plus rare l'union
des maires du département quand les
problèmes des collectivités locales sont
sont portés de façon assez importante
dans ces énoncés nos mails aulas et puis
un certain nombre de grandes
administrations ont mis en place je
pense à l'éducation nationale qui a mis
en place au niveau académique des
correspondants de correspondants par
région on sait que les académies des
régions sont pas toujours très très
congruente mais en gros on a une aucune
une ondée clean d'une façon régional
avec des correspondants pour l'éducation
nationale pour les ars avec des fortunes
diverses
certains travaillent beaucoup d'autres
moins et de ce point de vue on est
toujours en demande de ces réunions
parce qu'on s'aperçoit que c'est sur le
terrain en confrontant et je disais en
multipliant les abords différent des
différentes administrations répression
des fraudes d'un côté éducation
nationale de l'autre et protection
judiciaire de la jeunesse parce qu'on
s'aperçoit que par exemple un groupe
d'evian avec une famille ça intéresse
aussi bien les services sociaux lui
donna d'un département ça intéresse
évidemment l'éducation nationale ça peut
intéresser la protection judiciaire de
la jeunesse
quand on a affaire à des choses plus
pour de sa intéresse bien sûr la justice
s'intéresse également les maires qui
sont confrontés à parfois les
difficultés voilà alors vous le savez
mieux que mieux que nous nous
travaillons beaucoup aussi avec les
commissions d'enquêté parlementaires la
dernière a eu lieu dans cette danse est
assemblée au printemps du tout commencé
à l'automne 2012 et a donné ses
conclusions donc la commission d'enquêté
parlementaire sur les dérives sectaires
en matière de santé qui a donné ses
conclusions je prends en avril 2013
c'est un rapport qui a fait beaucoup de
bruit parce qu'il abordait d'abord
c'était le première que le sénat se
pencher sur ces dérives sectaires et
surtout il défricher un terrain
particulièrement peu aisé à appréhender
celui des dérives sectaires dans le
domaine de la santé de la thérapeutique
du soin
qui a longtemps été porté sous le
boisseau qui n'a pas été mise en avant
et qui était la montée qui est que le
sénat a réussi à mettre en évidence
allez je crois une certaine finesse dans
la différenciation entre la dérive
thérapeutique on trouve partout qui est
massive qui correspond sans doute un
état de crise de la médecine et de la
psychiatrie enfin dans nos relations
du point de vue relationnel avec les
patients et qui en fait ne nous concerne
pas nous nous occupons que nos dérives
sectaires les dérives thérapeutique
chacun pense ce qu'il veut
si elles ne sont pas de mal et puis
surtout ministère de la santé qui
devrait s'en occuper je dis bien qu'ils
devraient je m'arrête là mais nous nous
occupons que le viril secteurs qui sont
relativement peu nombreuses en ce
domaine et qui peuvent être dramatiques
puisque elle consiste souvent à l'arrêt
ou du moins la préconisation quand ce
n'est pas plus fort la jonction
d'arrêter un traitement éprouvé et
éprouvant au profit de traitement qui
n'ont non validées pour des maladies
importantes grave voire très grave et
nos cas les plus douloureux sont des
familles qui viennent voir en disant une
haine il n'a pas il a refusé d'aller à
l'hôpital la refusent de suivre une
chimiothérapie il a reçu de se faire
opérer et il est tombé dans les mains de
charlatans divers et variés qui ont nom
d'un esprit de système etc l'ont amené à
prendre des choses qui m'ont
du produit qu'ils n'ont non seulement
pas fait de bien mais on même accéléré
sa sonçon sa maladie et quand enfin on a
pu réussira à les amener là une personne
à l'hôpital c'est un cas qui nous avons
relaté fréquemment c'était trop tard et
il est décédé où elle est décédée
quelques quelques temps après d'une
façon d'une façon très très affreuse et
quand nous sommes tournés vers la trc
des personnes ou des groupes qui
l'avaient qui l'avait soigné évidemment
il ya plus personne
cette façon ils sont pas attaqua puisque
ce ne sont pas les professions de santé
reconnu
ils ne sont pas non plus attaquable
parce qu'ils voulaient expliquent que
toute façon la mallette était mortel et
que le lien de causalité entre à faire
entre une substance est un traitement ou
plutôt la préconisation de l'absence de
traitement est extrêmement difficile et
nous sommes souvent très désappointé du
point de vue judiciaire des suites que
nous avons alors nous avons aussi je le
mets dans un ordre voisins ce que
j'appellerai les psychothérapies
déviante
c'est très difficile de faire la
psychothérapie puisque c'est un contact
personnel avec une personne en
souffrance
l'emprise est constante entre le
psychothérapeute est la personne qu'il
va soigner et les psychologues et
psychanalystes et s'y tient connaissent
bien ça ça va bien et est sans rentrer
dans le détail
décrit par freud avec le transfert et la
façon de de résister quand on est le le
soignant vis-à-vis du transfert ou du
moins de l'aps panier bon là ce sont des
gens sans scrupules qui ont profité du
transfert pour effectivement pour
prendre le pouvoir sur la personne
capter ses souvenirs sa vie des secrets
intimes et puis finalement accusé de la
personne
quand je dis abusives dans tous les sens
du terme nous avons beaucoup beaucoup
d'affaires qui peuvent être très
destructrice du point de vue familial
social professionnel intime
sentimental et qui entraîne très souvent
des ruptures dramatique voire des
tentatives de suicide ou de suicides
enfin c'est quelque chose où des
compensations psychiatrique voilà pour
vous dire notre travail
donc nous recevons 3000 requête saisine
par an 3000 ce qui fait une dizaine par
jour la plupart arrivent maintenant par
voie électronique qui parfois y
electronics pose un certain nombre de
problèmes parce que nous devons pour
l'instant mais nous avons signé une
convention pour aller de l'avant avec
les services du premier ministre et pour
arriver à une gestion électronique du
courrier nous devons répondre d'une
façon très formaliser le président lula
à porter c'est à dire d'une façon avec
lettre bleu blanc rouge à la signature
manuscrite ce qui bon ce qui entraîne un
volume de papier je crois qu'on arrive
un petit peu aussi ce qui peut vous
intéresser volume de papier d'archivage
alors c'est très paradoxal parce qu'on
reçoit des mains de deux lignes ou de
trois lignes j'exagère à peine et nous
recevons une très forte matt et trey
formalisé très formel d'ailleurs
et c'est un autre aspect sur lequel je
voudrais insister très souvent quand il
manque de bois car nos mails sont nous
l'être son public
enfin on sait pas où elles partent on
peut être parfaitement manipuler aussi
par amel envers les filles dans le
demandent qu'une adresse postale
pourrait brouiller parfois de la numéro
de téléphone mais on a l'impression que
bien sûr un certain nombre de personnes
qui n'aiment pas notre façon de
travailler nous envoient des mails pour
nous c'était donc on a eu quelques
aventures dans le passé on écrit une
lettre très très formaliser et j'allais
dire très longue de pourquoi qui dit
simplement nous n'avons jamais eu de
renseignements ou d'un de deux
signalements sur ce groupe sur cette
personne sur cette méthode thérapeutique
mais cela ne vaut pas une cuite et
pourquoi là c'est un peu sec j'ai
l'impression que les personnes qui sont
en détresse qui reçoit ce courrier se
doivent se dire mais cette
administration qui l'a plus d'un mois me
répondre compris avec 3000 et que le
continent que nous sommes tous un peu de
temps ce ne ne se moque t elle pas un
peu nous vraiment pour ce type de
réponse alors nous avons privilégié pour
pallier cet inconvénient un contact plus
direct en jeux santons à travers hamels
et parfois pas toujours facile pour ça
qu'on demande d'un téléphone quand nous
sentons une véritable détresse quelque
chose qui nous semble lourd expire
finalement un cri d'alarmé nous
téléphone en personne leur demandant
s'ils veulent venir au rendez vous et
nous sommes une administration un
service du premier ministre qui nous
n'avons pas de patron téléphonique du
genre tapez 1 tapez 2 tapez 3
nous prenons les personnes au téléphone
on essaie de brouiller un petit peu leur
recours à cette horreur qui sauverait le
oui l'a fait pour téléphoner
voilà non je vous le dire parce que
c'est un peu plus le rôle puisqu'on peut
se demander que fois un officier de
police et un capitaine de gendarmerie
dans cette affaire comme ils ont une
habitude de recevoir des victimes
finalement c'est eux qui les reçoivent
une façon très discrète très très très
isolée en essayant alors on reçoit
surtout des familles je vous le disais
c'est un peu compliqué on essaie aussi
d' éviter l'instrumentalisation
quand un couple se sépare qu' on est
très vite amené à dire que l'autre
un comportement très curieux et ont tué
les enfants il ya de gros enjeux dont
qu'ils essayent de voir quelle est
exactement la situation
et puis de voir les signes dallaire par
exemple des personnes qui visiblement
serait prise dans un phénomène de
d'extorsion financières qui commence à
vendre des biens faire des donations
très importante des legs et donc on peut
qu'on peut effectivement orienter les
gens vers un parcours judiciaire un
parcours psychiatrique un parcours
psychologique à parcours de sécurité
voire juste pour une tutelle quand une
personne âgée se trouve en difficulté
dans une protection et mis sous
sauvegarde de justice voilà à partir de
là je vais essayer de répondre à votre
coeur de votre de vos préoccupations
donc j'ai dit qu'on ferait 3000 requête
par an je dois préciser que la plupart
viennent de particuliers mais il ya
aussi des institutions publiques je vous
disais un maire attend sté générale peut
nous peut de fait obtenir des
informations
un nouveau secteur ou sur une pratique à
risque et puis on a aussi des
témoignages de gens pour qui c'est trop
tard mais qui nous écrivent et j'ai
donné je vous donnerai sont des exemples
pour dire voilà ce qui m'est arrivé
votre votre travail c'est aussi de
mettre en garde les autres pour qu'ils
voulaient ne leur arrive pas la même
chose
bon vu la masse de renseignements
parfois intimes sensible parfois
extrêmement difficile que nous recevons
il nous semble évident qu'il faut
protéger l'anonymat
vers l'extérieur l'anonymat de ceux qui
nous écrivent ce qu'ils nous contactent
de ceux qui viennent nous voir leurs
témoignages certains ouvertes des
certificats médicaux
il ya deux psychiatres à l'appui et voir
des états bancaire quand ils veulent
montrer qu'une personne âgée dans alger
est en train de se faire dépouiller on
nous amène des relevés bancaires enfin
voyez c'est voilà ils vont nous dire ce
que vous en pensez c'est quand même 10
que
mon père la mère restée seule et c'est
en soient arrivées avoir dépensé autant
d'argent bon c'est extrêmement c'est
donc ce sont des données pour nous très
sensible évidemment nous nous les
protégeons et nous le rassurons nous le
rassurons le parfait anonymat et le
refus est évidemment de toute cette
diffusion publique de ces de ces données
je me le dire puisque je m'en étais tu
paies dans une vie antérieure que nous
sommes aujourd'hui avec les victimes de
dérives sectaires dans la situation où
nous étions ya peut-être vingt ans avec
les victimes de violences faites aux
femmes que dans un cadre conjugal ou le
plus souvent où périt conjugale
complications de la peur des victimes on
ne peut pas traiter d'une façon je
dirais comme les autres victimes
attention particulière je pense on vous
rassurer que c'est très faible par
rapport au grand nombre de femmes
victimes de violence mais c'est la même
intensité et je dirais le même à bord
compliqué de victimes qui sont des
victimes
comment dire complexe qui voudrait que
ça s'arrange ne sont pas des victimes
d'un vol ou d'un cambriolage ou de
violence la volerie violence classique
qui arrive dans un commissariat brigade
de gendarmerie
nous avons affaire à des gens qu un
rapport particulier le lie avec leur
comme dans les violences conjugales avec
la personne qui est l'auteur alors c'est
sous emprise
c'est où il ya eu quelques procès vous
avez vu on a la justice a hésité entre
caux complicité ou victime elle-même
pour les gens qui étaient en fait les
complices de je pense à la sphère de
lisieux par exemple et a finalement
déclassé au rang de victime c'est le
terme déclassé pas être un peu est un
peu péjoratif mais a dit ce ne sont pas
des conteurs se sont fait des victimes
eh bien on est parfois nous avec cette
difficulté de rencontrer des personnes
qui ont un rapport très extrêmement en
vue avec la personne qui leur fait du
mal qui voudrait que ça s'arrange qui je
crois toujours à ce qu'il raconte le
portement mauvais
c'est en fait c'est une dérive c'est une
déviation
alors c'est très délicat parce que nous
savons que nous avons énormément de deux
dépôts de plaintes qui sont avec des
retraits dons qui sont très décent nous
avons des gens qui ne déposent pas
plainte alors qu'ils sont partis avec on
leur explique et c'est bon nous déposons
plainte parfois quand la personne est au
nom de l'article 40 du code de procédure
pénale c'est dans le décret de 2002 nous
fait obligation de le faire quand le
mais nous ne faisons pas
systématiquement à la place aussi des
personnes parce que d'abord ne sont pas
tous les ans et deuxièmement c'est c'est
une démarche qui elle même fait sortir
la personne de son de son état de deux
délits câble d'emprise où elle se trouve
donc il faut qu'elle puisse rassembler
ses forces et parfois et du courage pour
aller dire ça s'arrête
et donc nous avons parfois c'est cette
difficulté avec des victimes dont le
terme ambigu et sans doute un tout petit
peu trop péjoratif des dix victimes
compliqué à gérer
excusez moi de le dire comme cela alors
je vous nomme ici peut-être pour faire
une petite pause quelques témoignages
qui sont arrivés alors que bien
évidemment je voulais je vais vous les
lire très rapidement une jeune femme par
exemple qu'un numéro 1 une jeune femme
rejetée par son ami qui a
considérablement changé de comportement
après adhésion à la nouvelle acropole
c'est un mouvement extrêmement
autoritaire venue de l'amérique du sud
qui fait soi disant des conférences
philosophiques et qui en fait tu prends
les gens et pour beaucoup d'argent elle
décrit dans son témoignage des stages
d'initiation d'endurance et lectures à
haute voix les oeuvres philosophiques du
fondateur de mouvements durant des
heures où l'émission de co des dons sont
investis les membres elle interpelle ses
jeunes femmes celles de john dubois
novembre la miviludes sur les moyens de
contrer les activités de la nouvelle
acropole
c'est pas très sympa ce que la nouvelle
acropole est un mouvement qui est très
puissant qui a beaucoup d'argent
deuxième cas malgré la prescription des
faits une victime de monsieur mickaël
hay 29 alors c'est un mouvement qui
dirigea mouvement qui s'appelle la
fraternité blanche universel c'est un
mouvement suprématiste racialiste
absolument effrayant mais
il ya beaucoup essaimé dans beaucoup de
pays anglo saxons d'abord afrique du sud
et puis maintenant en europe donc il
estime souhaite s'entretenir avec un
concept vie l'udps afin que la société
tout entière sache ce que les mineurs ou
les jeunes abus peut subir en matière de
violences sexuelles notamment en
certains mouvements une incidente
évidemment ça m'a beaucoup plus réactif
et proactif dès qu'il s'agit de mineurs
parce que nous avons grâce au code pénal
et au juge des enfants une plus grande
faculté et même une obligation
alors que des personnes majeures
malheureusement elles sont une grande
liberté de faire y compris des sottises
à peu abominable quoi bon donc nous
sommes beaucoup très réactifs et agiles
mineurs victimes d'un groupe qui
s'appelle galactus ou non qui s'appelle
iso zanussi soit livré son témoignage
afin que d'autres se trouvent pas piéger
une expérience aussi néfaste que celle
qu'elle a vécu et dont elle dit être
sorti grâce à l'aide de son entourage et
la pratique de la religion catholique
heureusement elle a pu trouver une
écoute attentive une adaptée des témoins
de jéhovah a été victime à l'adolescente
abus sexuels je m'attendrais plus si
vous posez une question sur ces
questions très compliquées les témoins
de jéhovah elle souhaite apporter son
témoignage afin que les parents témoins
de jéhovah eux mêmes pris conscience du
tort qu'ils causent à leurs enfants
on navigue en strictement la règle des
deux témoins de la watch l'organisation
internationale des témoins de jéhovah
cet adepte si ce qu'elle subit encore
aujourd'hui soit trente ans après les
faits les conséquences psychologiques de
ces de ces agressions 5e qui exemple une
mère de famille capitalisant psychiatrie
est reçue de nos fréquentations de
thérapeutes son mari indique qu'elle
pratiquait des séances d'hypnose qui se
déroulait toute la nuit
est-il besoin de préciser qu ensuite
elle s'est enfuie avec le thérapeute un
ex adeptes et témoins de jéhovah nous
demande de ne pas dévoiler nos sources
en dépit de l'autorisation que nous
avons obtenus tribunal de consulter les
documents détenus par le musée rude et
c'est une réaction suite à une décision
du conseil d'état du 22 avril 2013 qui
nous a posé beaucoup de questions dans
la mesure où j'ai ici est vraiment son
sa lettre en disant surtout je vous en
supplie j'ai encore des membres de ma
famille dans tout mouvement si je veux
continuer allez allez voir ils
fréquentaient même fugitivement et je
dois garder mon anonymat se conduit bien
sûr promis voilà je voulais vous donner
aussi mais je vous donnerai la fiche 5,5
exemple de livres récemment parus qui
explique bien ce phénomène compliqué de
l'emprise mentale
donc j'ai choisi à dessein avec madame
bâ lèvres dans tous les domaines de
l'enfant talent je dirais pour que tout
le monde en un petit peu pour lui
moi anciens légionnaires du christ de
monsieur n'aviez plus léger c'est un
ancien séminaire regroupement
séminaristes ce groupement catholique
très particulier qui a beaucoup défrayé
la chronique en 2008 et qui viendront de
livrer un témoignage 50 cauchemar d'eric
et julie martin qui sont un jeune couple
qui était dans la sphère de lisieux qui
étaient des victimes épouvantable de la
plus pouvant table affaires de lisieux
où il avait réduit en esclavage des
personnes un peu immature et même
certains malades mentaux pendant des
années avec des choses tellement dur il
a fallu que les procès l'appel et le
premier procès tenu à huis clos n'étions
pas armés de crise de villepin' que la
belle-soeur de la de la famille dite de
la famille rock une bouffe lamquin et
qui l'a mis sous emprise une famille
pendant dix ans par un escroc
particulièrement psychologiquement
habile le silence et lahoud solveig
ready
ça c'est sûr
ah oui alors c'est sûr le mouvement
charismatique d'origine catholique taper
les béatitudes qui a aussi défrayé la
chronique par de lourds de la sphère de
en particulier de touche mans sexuels
sur des mineurs et de l'enfer à
l'endroit de myriam de claire qui est un
livre très intéressant d'une jeune femme
partie à 15 ans dans un groupe propose
soixante huitard pour naples et les
enfants de dieu qui se promenaient dans
les rues de nos villes avec guitare et
très sympathique
il s'appelait ensuite la famille et qui
était en fait un enfermement absolument
atroce dans un groupe e sous l'autorité
d'un gourou et qui s'est retrouvée quand
on est sorti à 26 ans avec quatre
enfants de plusieurs pères différents
bons famille je passe mais ça avec
beaucoup beaucoup de jeu les dires de
sérieux et en même temps d'un regard
très critique alors je voudrais
maintenant dans une deuxième partie vous
parler de notre position face à l'accès
aux documents administratifs dont vous
l'avez compris nous sommes effectivement
très très attentif à ne jamais mettre en
danger les personnes qui nous écrivent
d'un certain point de vue nous
confortons totalement à la loi du 7
juillet ce sont 18 ans et en particulier
à son article 6 qui protège qui fait
état d exception constituons vraiment
dans la sécurité des personnes nous
avons aussi la pression parce que nous
sommes beaucoup critiqué par des
mouvements donc l'adversaire des
mouvements sectorisé adverse que cette
fois n'était pas fait pour protéger ses
mouvements pour protéger les victimes
donc quand on nous demande au nom de la
loi du 7 juin 78 de donner toutes nos
sources en disant vous nous attaquez non
nous nous protégeons les victimes tacon
personnes encore une fois je me dis ici
solennellement dans le cadre de cette
mission parlementaire
nous ne jouons jamais et doctrines je
dis toujours c'est une forme de
plaisanterie mais l'existant en france
200 adorateurs de l'oignon chacun dans
ce qui veux me sont des gens absolument
charmant qui ont motivé nous qui sont
venus nous voir à plusieurs reprises
pour demander que pour ne faire préciser
que nous considérons pas comme un
mouvement de dérives sectaires
on en rentre on en sort on paie une
cotisation pour tr min mais les gens
sont évidemment libres de croire ce
qu'ils veulent donc c'est pour nous un
faux problème
nous nous intéressons qu'aux d'hélico
crime qu contravention coupe comme
ultime qu'aux personnes nous sentons
qu'elles sont partis sur des processus
et les gens perdus finalement leur libre
arbitre c
c'est vraiment ça et donc nous n'avons
aucun intérêt et je dirais que nous
n'avons aucun avis sur les mouvements et
je n'ai dit on nous sommes suffisamment
nombreux et pluraliste nous-mêmes pour
savoir qu'il ya une infinité de
conviction de croyance dans dans ce pays
donc nous sommes extrêmement attentifs à
ce que l'anonymat est l'identité de nos
victimes et je dirai au delà même du nom
et c'est l'adresse nous ne prenons
jamais la ville nous ne donnons jamais
des circonstances nous ne pourrons
jamais les dates parce que nous avons en
face de nous des mouvements qui ont des
sortes de services de renseignements
voir de barbouzes qui peuvent
parfaitement remontés à la surface et à
la source des renseignements dont nous
sommes extrêmement attentifs de ne pas
comme jamais communiquer des
informations sur les personnes physiques
de préserver évidemment le secret
médical que nous avons été dit call et
les secrets de la vie privée alors nous
recevons beaucoup de demandes
la cada considère logiquement que les
documents produits reçus par le milieu
dans le cadre de sa mission de service
public constitue documents
administratifs au sens de l'article 1er
de la loi du 17 juillet 1918 et nous le
comprenons parfaitement ce que nous
pouvons constater c'est que au nom de
cette fois le 1er juillet nous sommes
comment dire bombarde excusez-moi la
familiarité du terme en tout cas
extrêmement sollicité par ses mouvements
alors ces mouvements sont en général
toujours les mêmes alors ils ont parfois
certain nombre de noms de deux noms
différents
il c'est à dire ce que nous appelons
identités multiples alors nous avons par
exemple la scientologie s'appelle
éthique et libertés c'est dans le xiième
elle s'appelle également comités
citoyens pour les droits de l'homme ce
qui entraîne parfois une confusion avec
la commission nationale consultative des
droits de l'homme les parlementaires
reçoivent en général assez cdh et vie
mais pourquoi ils m'interpellent là
dessus bon assez cdh s'est fait une
spécialisation dans les hôpitaux
psychiatriques et l'hospitalisation
psychiatrique
les témoins de jéhovah ont comme autres
candidats paraissent un quelque chose
qui s'appelle un comité de liaison
hospitalier qui pénètre les hôpitaux les
maisons de retraite les maisons pour
handicapés et entend expliquer incendie
être invité la vraie parole des témoins
de jéhovah
nous nous méfions terriblement nous
avons mis notre dernier rapport au
premier ministre de se qui se pénètrent
dans les maisons de nous les ehpad où
les mets les établissements
médico-sociaux qui reçoivent du public
âgé ou handicapé dans la mesure où les
directeurs consulte fréquemment disant
il ya la fois liberté de conviction ils
peuvent recevoir qu'ils veulent pour
leur porter un secours spirituel dans
dix ans évidemment nous sommes d'accord
avec vous mais surveiller quand même que
au final ça ne se traduisent pas quand
même par part dans l'affaiblissement de
la capacité contributive de la personne
parce qu'on a déjà eu ce genre de cas
voilà
nous avons comme ça cinquante deux
signalements qui sont émergents
on est quelque part aussi des donneurs
d'alert nous avons vu émerger ce
problème des personnes âgées en
institution dans ces dernières années
nous le savons mais j'ai une toute
petite chose c'est que le temps
malheureusement c'est cool très vite et
il ne reste plus qu'une dizaine de
minutes dont il faudrait voilà en
conservant l'essentiel
je termine en disant que nous répondons
favorablement aux dons de communication
quand ils document que nous détenons
sont des documents j'allais dire qu'ils
ne mettent pas en cause l'identité des
personnes s'activent donc nous écrivons
après que la cada demande et nous en
voyons les articles de presse les
extrêmes décision judiciaire
les documents sont en général recueillis
par la recherche documentaire livre sur
internet ou dans des ouvrages des
publications de chercheurs etc
on nous reproche souvent dire vous nous
envoyez notre propre littérature bah oui
mais c'est plus qu'on se forge une
opinion sur un certain nombre de deux
questions voilà je je je compte nous
continue donc la refuser tout ce qui
pourrait mettre en jeu la sécurité des
personnes je voudrais simplement que
nous recevons beaucoup de sollicitations
parfois étranges parfois des années
après j'ai un exemple ici on nous
demandait de dire de justifier d'envoyer
ses la lettre attitude pertes et 2011
je vais vous lire ça va être très rapide
donc c'était entre son premier ministre
c'est ça qui sait quelques lunes
monsieur le premier ministre
quatre réunions du conseil d'orientation
de la miviludes alors il est parti le 23
juillet 2013 quatre réunions du conseil
d'orientation de la miviludes le fameux
concertation large vous parlez sont nuls
9 février 22 juin 5 octobre en hausse en
2011 auxquels madame picard présidente
de l'unadfi en scène parlementaire
assister en tant que présidente de
l'unadfi de vous demandant l'application
de la loi du 7 juillet ce sont 18
modifier le 12 avril 2000 l'accès aux
documents administratifs relatives à ces
quatre réunions du conseil d'orientation
tels que compte-rendu procès verbaux
directive instruction note statistique
après occultation on éventuellement sur
non communicables tels que précisés dans
la nuit à 3 etc
en vous remerciant par avance et ça leur
parle de la scientologie voilà donc bien
sûr vous alerter à la fois madame pic
rares du fait qu on voulait savoir ce
que deux ans après ce qu'elle ait pu
dire mais le problème c'est que nous
avons des fonctionnaires qui sont pas là
titre personnel notion de réunion et
églises désigné délégué par leur
administration pour souci comment ça se
passe le directeur de vie au sous
directeur qui dit au chef de bureau donc
pourquoi mettre son nom donc donc nous
envoyons des pièces stabilité d'une
façon je vais dire grossière y en a
partout et en plus voyants nous demande
pas nous ce qu'on nous montre ce qu'est
olympique avec nous nos réunions bon il
faut savoir aussi mais nous l'avons
appris d'une façon très forte 8 parce
que par une lettre de la mairie de
bordeaux que quand nous intervenons nous
sommes intervenus avec bordeaux sur un
colloque et lancement de par un avocat
autre bordeaux de mettre picotin qui fut
un ancien parlementaire de qui voulait
un peu titillé des pouvoirs publics la
mairie de bourges où il avait donc
trouvé un cadre très très prestigieux
pour dire tout tout ce qu'il faudrait
faire de plus et il a souvent raison sur
les anti-sectes et donc il a cité la
miviludes qui était représenté par un
conseiller donc la mairie de bordeaux a
reçu une demande d'information sur le
fait pour qu'on n'y était coordonne tout
et c'est que
et iront devant les dossiers de demande
de subvention de 2 les délibérations du
conseil municipal les correspondances
échangées entre la mairie et assemble
d'associations qui était présente
il compte la miviludes ce n'est pas une
association et donc on nous demande sans
arrêt y compris aux organismes
extérieurs
on a demandé je lui ai appris par le
jeune magistrat qui est chez nous comme
certains général depuis trois mois et l
as des as et jeu au près avant que
chaque fruit s'occuper donc des dérives
sectaires suivant à la direction de les
affaires criminelles et gratter grands
procès des dérives sectaires
il faut une réalise pour le pour le pour
la ministre pour le ministre et donc ils
recevaient également des kim était le
mobile une demande de toutes les pièces
qu'ils pouvaient fournit enfin voyez c
c'est à dire c'est une guérilla
administrative au nom de la loi 17 juin
ce sont 18 alors que pour nous elle
paraissait pas être destiné à lutter
contre le travail de nos missions comme
la l'autre voilà je voudrais un
conclusion monsieur le président vous
dire que pour nous la transparence
administrative est une avancée
démocratique fondamental est inéluctable
d'ailleurs à laquelle la miviludes se
conforment
toutefois les demandes de communication
de documents qu'elle reçoit soit
effectuée en fait par des lobbys et des
groupes bien connus et n'ont comme seul
objectif de combattre notre action est
donc l'action des pouvoirs publics les
mêmes notre légitimité
en l'état actuel de la loi de 1978 si
vous posez la question je dirai qu'elle
me paraît équilibré et de l'avis général
tous les conseils que j'ai recueillis
avant cette audition et nous convient
très bien dans ses réactions actuelles
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
d'avoir des rapporteurs bien écoutez je
pense que vous avez à peu près tout dit
vous avez bien résumé votre action ils
la difficulté que qui incombent
moi je me posais une question mais c'est
peut-être une question extrêmement
difficile est ce que pour vous c'est
toujours simple de faire la frontière
entre une une église reconnus et traités
par le ministère de l'intérieur dans le
cadre du bureau des cultes et qui on va
dire estampillé comme tel et une dérive
sectaire
est-ce que parfois vous n'avez pas des
difficultés concernant les limites de la
limite c'est une question que je me
posais et du coup ça pose ensuite la
question des documents évidemment oui
bien sûr ça fait partie de notre travail
beaucoup que le bureau des cultes au
dessus alors on travaille également avec
les églises elle-même qui sont très
différentes sur l'organisation france
pin rouge aujourd'hui beaucoup plus
paysage religieux est devenu beaucoup
plus plus rien
en même temps je remarque par exemple il
ya beaucoup d'églises et j'avais envie
évangéliques charismatiques néo
évangélique bon il ya au sein de la
confédération nationale des évangélistes
france apvf qui fait partie du mouvement
protestant un observatoire des dérives
sectaires en milieux évangéliques dirigé
par un pasteur basterds on joue qui est
près de montpellier qui avait créé un
travail très quotidiennement par ce que
sont des micros groupe donc ce qui nous
ce qui nous pose problème selon ces
micro groupes tels en fait ils puissance
de nifa secret mais très discret et père
yvon lieu dans ce milieu très fermé on
le trouve dans toutes les autres
religions alors très récemment la
conférence des évêques de france qui
avait un bureau nouvelles croyances et
dérives sectaires a scindé et nous avons
rencontré deux responsables du bureau
des prises sectaire la soeur marie
sorlin qui est un ancien juge
d'instruction et qui est devenu
qui donc l'état religieux scène d'années
qui est jugée l'officialité de dijon et
qui donc a pris ça vraiment à bras le
corps les dérives sectaires au milieu
charismatique catholique on va dire sa
façon un peu rapide comme cela est aidé
par un évêque auxiliaire monsieur le
basque qui lui même donc travaille
beaucoup sur l'église de france à la
pleine confiance de de monseigneur
compte il nous travaillons également
très bien les que l'union est bouddhiste
de france qui nous signalent tel ou tel
est le paysage est moins connu un je
dirais par nous donc il nous signale que
tel ou tel groupe et qui sont attentifs
ou que celui-là d'adhérer à l'ue bf donc
ne pose pas de problème voilà donc
n'avons nous avons bien sûr des
interrogations mais nous n'avons pas en
général de difficultés parce que
j'allais dire dans ce type de mouvement
la dérive sectaire quand elles arrivent
ce repère très vite
d'abord parce que heureusement tous les
adeptes ont pas et donc et certains
viennent nous voir en disant ça va pas
ça ça dérive vous devriez faire quelque
chose et nous pouvons voir un signal
dallaire donc on commence à regarder et
en général je vais dire l'auto
régulation se fait par c'est dans
l'église elle-même enfin dans les
églises dans les grandes confessions
religieuses elle-même merci nos
questions alors voudrais saluer la
présence de jean jacques hyest notre
président qui a pu se libérer à venir
nous rejoindre et qui a peut-être une
question à poser
et pour avoir être quelques années à la
miviludes et puis avait avant dont je
connais un petit peu et problématiques
donc j'ai pas de questions mais je
remercie président bis qu'au contraire
la voix apporter toutes les informations
nécessaires et et fut notre point de vue
deux missions d'information parce que
évidemment on ne fait pas une mission
d'information sur les c'est tout c'est
ça c'est ça d'autres sujets qui est qui
est toujours d'ailleurs si j'ai
peut-être qu'une question comme elle
sait les dérives sectaires dans le monde
de l'islam à tous que tout ce qu'on
apprend aujourd'hui des jeunes qui sont
embrigadés qui partent et cetera au
tchad comme comme nous l'a dit que nous
l'a révélé nuisent de l'intérieur plus
trentaine quand même
et comment détecter ou parce que c'est
une dérive sectaire aussi ça non
pardon monsieur le pastis ans mais je
pense quand même que c'est vous regardez
ça aussi alors monsieur le président si
vous pouvez donner une réponse oui c'est
fait partie de ce que je dis dans le
ronron témoins nous sommes des donneurs
des retraites si on a augmenté le
phénomène dans ses rangs deux ans un
monsieur center en deux ans on n'en
avait jamais signalement de ce type
très vite on a vu donc depuis deux ans
des famines ou alors des familles soient
d'origine musulmane de mai qui via liens
directs chez mon fils ma fille bon soin
de famille qui ne sont pas d'origine
musulmane d'alors bon alors on ne donne
pas trop de jalibert de signalements
parce que quand on est dans une histoire
de départ dans un pays étranger ça nous
concerne pas ses plaies c'est une dérive
sectaire là c'est un problème de
évidemment beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
lourd nous ce sont plutôt des jeunes
filles qui tout d'un coup je vais dire
dérive
au sens religieux du terme d'une famille
qu'elle soit d'origine musulmane ou pas
mais qui s'enferme vraiment dans une
conception extrêmement étroites delà de
la religion alors c'est un peu délicat
c'est un peu délicat parce que tant que
les lois et donc celles que nous avons
voté récents ne sont pas transgresser
chacun est libre de croire ce qu'il veut
donc voilà et on n'ose y donne beaucoup
plus de jeunes filles que de jeunes gens
mais je pense que c'est parce que nous
ne paie plus dont ils sont plus dans
l'interrogation familial que dans
l'interrogation je veux dire au public
ou ou sécurité publique voilà bien
m'écouter je crois que nous avons
terminé notre audition merci beaucoup
monsieur le président mesdames merci
d'être venus également et je rappelle
aux membres de cette mission que
exceptionnellement les auditions
reprendront mercredi prochain après midi
la semaine prochaine et où nous
entendrons journaliste d'investigation
qui font un grand usage de données
publiques pour les enquêtes et analyses
voilà je vous remercie tous la séance et
le merci voilà vous avez pu suivre
l'audition de serge blisko le président
de la miviludes devant la mission
d'information sur l'accès aux données
administratives tout de suite ces 24
heures sénat présenté par delphine
gérard
en mai 1996
les sept moines français de tibhirine